Ross Tucker former NFL lineman Ross
Tucker football podcast worked for
Sirius XM Westwood One he worked the
sidelines for the Eagles in the Saints
game for Westwood One and joins us on
the program Ross good morning thanks for
joining us what's the one thing that
stood out the most
with the Saints Eagles game to you oh my
gosh Dan probably the noise I mean I
still have a headache you know and I've
been in a lot of stadiums throughout my
time that was insane
yesterday I mean that that probably was
the loudest environment for a football
game I've ever been in I had some
buddies that came to the game and they
say it was by far the most day ever
heard so that was a huge huge factor in
the game I thought you know the Eagles
jumped offsides a couple times and
really after those first two drives they
just could never really get it going
again and some of that was injuries some
of that was you know had to take a
timeout to not do a delay a game one so
just I guess the amount of noise they
can generate was the biggest thing it
has to be but maybe that's because I
still have a headache with two minutes
to go in the game who did you think was
winning I thought I really thought Dan
that the Eagles were gonna score a
touchdown but that they were gonna score
too quickly and that Brees was gonna
take the Saints down to get a field goal
when they got the ball at the 27 I
really thought that the Eagles should
take the two-minute rather than try to
get one more playoff I mean you're at
the 27 yard line you still have a
timeout that's plenty of time in the NFL
the way things are now spiking the ball
plenty of time for them to get a
touchdown and it seemed like they
hurried it a little bit now that's not
the reason why al Shawn Geoffrey dropped
the ball or they weren't successful
because obviously the ball went right to
Al Shean I never been in great shape at
about the 20 yard line coming back from
the two minute but I was really thinking
the Eagles are hurrying up a little too
much here I had that much faith that
they were going to get a touchdown and I
just thought they might leave too much
time
Brie's on the back end and I wasn't sure
about this I go back to the national
title game when Knicks save and I
thought was very very uncharacteristic
of him by going for it on fourth down
you have a fake pun it just felt like he
knew that he was in trouble against
Clemson when I I saw some of the
decisions made by Sean Payton I I
started to think the same thing like you
know everybody knew you're gonna fake
the punt and you're still able to
convert I I wasn't sure if Sean Payton
thought maybe we're in trouble with this
Eagles team and we're gonna have to do
some things desperate time desperate
measure what do you make of some of
those calls I think you're exactly right
then and that that's what he was
thinking they had to do something
because even though they had gotten the
interception by Lattimore you know the
Eagles that stuffed them again and they
were actually fortunate you know the the
earlier when Brandon Graham knocked the
ball out of Brees hands if Brandon
Graham just holds on to that ball the
Eagles get at least some points there
and they're up 17 nothing even if they
just get a few goals there so I think
Payton felt like almost like you did in
the Super Bowl when he called the onside
kick against the Colts I think he just
felt like he had to do something to try
to change the momentum of the game
because even after a Lattimore's
interception where she thought okay that
might change things
they still got stopped and the weird
thing about that too is just like the
national championship game ban the
Eagles had their defense out there I
mean the Eagles had Fletcher kosnett to
play Fletcher Cox got hurt on so it's
not like they ran a fake pun against a
punt return team the Eagles had their
defense out there which give a lot of
credit to my quest Dolph and the Saints
special teams coaches because you're not
supposed to be successful on a fake punt
when the other team has their defense
out there I mean you have linebackers
and safeties blocking Fletcher Cox and
like hello ting nada on a fourth and
short but they went with you know a
silent count direct snap and even though
the Eagles had their defense out there
it almost looked like they weren't ready
for it they kind of got knocked back
talking to Ross Tucker he was on the
sidelines working for Westwood One
yesterday New Orleans Eagles Saints what
kind of decision do you think the Eagles
make on Nick Foles well I think they're
gonna try to trade them and I think
they'll probably be successful trading
him what I think is the interesting
dynamic of it Dan
is they're gonna give him the twenty
million dollar option he's gonna buy
back the two million dollars I think to
buy out of that to buy his freedom and
then he's gonna force them to either
franchise tag him or he'll be a free
agent if he's a free agent he's gonna
get a lot of money from somebody because
he Joe Flacco and Dwayne Haskins are
gonna be the three most highly sought
after quarterbacks this offseason for
the teams that need and want them
Jaguars dolphins Redskins maybe Giants
so I think there's gonna be a really
nice market for foals the question is do
the Eagles franchise them so that's a
higher number and then trade him which
would probably end up being for less
than a third-round pick but it might at
least enable them to get him out of the
NFC and trade him potentially to
Jacksonville I think that's actually
what the decision will come down to let
Nick be free for a third-round pick but
then have to worry about where he might
go
versus trade them for potentially less
because if you're fools
you're not going to agree to a contract
extension with the other team why would
you because if you do that then - then
you're hurting the team you're going to
because then the Eagles will be able to
get more in a trade it's going to be the
number-one topic this offseason that and
what the Ravens do with Flacco it's
fascinating that both those franchises
are gonna try to trade those guys that
have both won Super Bowls for them okay
but if I put this question to you what's
your answer you can have foals Flacco
you can have Haskins out of Ohio State
or Kyler Murray
for how long well Marie you're gonna get
for five years
Haskins you're getting five years for
the first-round draft pick and then
you're probably gonna be looking at
foals and Flacco for two or three years
you know you know that dance I think it
depends on where you feel like your team
is that so if I'm the Jaguars and I
think we're good like I think we have a
good defense I think we have a good
offensive line we just had a bad year
and didn't get it done a quarterback if
I'm the Jaguars I'm going for fools or
Flacco and I'm probably taking Falls
just based on what we've seen recently
I'm probably given foals that that
chance although I think foals Flacco is
a good debate if I am the Giants and
I've got young say Quan Barclay I'm kind
of skewing young and rebuilding young
Odell Beckham jr. but if I'm the Giants
I probably lean more towards Dwayne
Hoskins or Kyler Murray and of those
guys I'd go with Haskins because I you
know he's just unbelievably accurate he
moves well enough I like the idea of him
throwing Odell on Ingram and I think I'm
gonna get plenty out of the running game
with sake one I think there's less risk
with Haskins then there is with Murray
so I'll go foals for the team that
thinks they're gonna win right away and
Haskins for a team that's rebuilding a
little bit more what's the rain Rams
game plan in New Orleans this weekend
what should it be I think they're gonna
try to probably start out like they did
against the Cowboys that was the single
most stunning result of the weekend to
me Dan and by the way the other thing is
that I just can't believe we had to have
seen what like twenty fourth down
attempts this weekend I mean the NFL has
changed man that there's so many times
they go for fourth down they would not
have done that you know five ten years
ago I mean there was it seemed like
three or four or five almost every game
but other than that my other big
takeaway was the team that won the
battle up front won every game but it
wasn't
Celie predictive right like I don't have
thought the coasts were better up front
than the Chiefs that was clearly not the
case in that game and I would have
thought the Cowboys were better up front
than the Rams
and the Rams ran it right down the
Cowboys throat so even though we know
that the team that wins up front usually
wins it's not as predictive as maybe we
thought it was certainly hell I thought
it would go in those games
I think the Rams will probably start out
seeing if they can run the ball at the
Saints especially since they lost
Sheldon Rankin's but the Saints have had
pretty good run defense throughout the
year so if that's not working that's the
beauty of kind of McVeigh and what the
Rams have they can change up and go to
the air and probably try to attack the
saint safeties but it'd mean if you
rushed for almost 300 yards with both
running backs against a pretty good run
defense and the Cowboys I'd at least try
that first if I were the ramps should
the Patriots be underdogs yes I think
they should because the Chiefs have been
a better team throughout the year and
the Chiefs are playing at home we've
seen playing at home gives you a
distinct advantage arrowheads the
loudest outdoor stadium I ever played in
in my life can even louder than Seattle
I just think they remember being a
backup for the Bills in O 3 and
Arrowhead was so loud I was just like
playing that none of the guys got hurt
because I really did not want to go in
that game we were getting smoked I was
like I wanted no part of going in and
trying to block those guys with that
crazy noise silent count so yeah plus I
mean Holmes hasn't had a bad game all
year and the way they played defensively
against the Colts it's kind of weird
that their defense hasn't been better I
mean Chris Jones
Justin Houston D Ford the way the Chiefs
played and the way they played all year
they should be the favorites and I think
you know the Patriots they were awesome
obviously yesterday but that's not
really how they played all year so I
agree with that with that betting line
yeah but it feels like it's rare for
Brady to be in this situation
but it feels like he loves the fact that
he's an underdog it feels like they've
been underdogs this entire season that
you know what the end is near for Brady
Belichick you know the Patriots dynasty
but here they are you can't kill him you
know they just can't kill them and they
came up with a game plan that you
wouldn't have thought that they would
have been relying on Sony Michelle to
dominate against that charger defense
but you know that that's Bella check
making adjustments here and you have to
factor this in whether it comes down to
it or not whether it's you know fact or
fiction but it's Belichick versus Andy
Reid and we know that that usually goes
to Bill Belichick I would agree with
that I think that a Chiefs fan would
tell you it's a new world order with
Patrick mahomes in there and we'll see
it should be an awesome game I still
can't believe how badly the Patriots
embarrassed the Chargers it was a
terrific game plan I wasn't expecting
that
I'll give Belichick Brady McDaniels the
nod from a game plan standpoint in any
one game situation but you know the
Patriots have not been as good on the
road in the playoffs as they have been
at home you think about the road playoff
games they've lost in Denver I was with
them when we lost in Denver at the end
of the old five season you know when
they lose a lot of times they lose in
the playoffs on the road so this is the
Chiefs chance this is Andy Reid's chance
this is the one safe travels Ross always
got good to talk to you buddy
absolutely take care guys that's a Ross
chunker Ross Tucker football podcast
also working for Westwood One during the
playoffs working this Saints in the
Eagles sidelines for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]